our next guest in 2012 the Washington
Redskins transformed the franchise by
selecting a quarterback they also took
this guy in the fourth round that year
while always considered too talented
quarterback his wild ways off the field
certainly a constant concern for teams
in 2014 he actually ordered three extra
desserts at the Cheesecake Factory then
in 2015
actually considered getting tinted
windows on his minivan but decided not
to because he didn't want to create the
perception he's hiding anything he's
known for asking questions and then
walking away before anyone gets to
answer them for example do you like that
maybe it didn't give me a chance to
answer please welcome Kurt
okay it's Kirk Cousins but people said
you know hey you keep saying Kirk
Cousins see you on T or ke u RT so leave
no doubt I had to get the extra ke Kirk
D cousins now would you consider
changing your name to Curt so then I
would make it easier on well you know
with the intro you just gave me I think
Curt should be my alter ego that's the
guy who does order three desserts and
does tint the van window so I'm trying
to be more Curt in 2019 than Kirk what
do you do what's the like you ever got
in trouble oh man like what's the worst
thing that you've done I uh as a high
school senior I got a detention force
leaving campus for lunch went to a Taco
Bell Oh crazy that one hurt did the
scouts know about that I may have been
able to hide that one come on yeah that
one slipped under the rug Bay that was
why I slipped to the fourth round I
don't know man
I could see where you dropped down with
that I just saw when it drew Locke of
Missouri mm-hmm
they somebody went back and and realized
that he cheated on a math test in ninth
grade Wow no I'm serious
now I don't like wood that I guess they
want to know if he was gonna tell the
truth but you had these questions at the
comp did you get really goofy yeah the
most goofy one that I got was I might
have been at the Senior Bowl because
nowadays the Senior Bowl is becoming
more and more like the combine but a
scout from the Patriots showed me a
bunch of training a bunch of cards like
just game cards and then he did this
whole interview 1050 man interview and
at the end he wanted to know what the
cards were how many I could remember and
I didn't do that great I remembered a
few but it was just really odd and that
was it and and he had been doing a long
time and there was really nobody else
who did something like that but yeah
just playing mind games
so you're just seeing those cards not
realizing that he wants to know what
your retention is I think he put him in
front of me just to kind of
you just said just absorb those for a
minute so I knew all right I got to
memorize many as I can but then you have
a 10 15 minute conversation then you
recall I don't know I think
quarterbacking is more about how much
can you process in two and a half
seconds not so much how much can you
remember over 15 minutes so but
everybody's got their own test no I said
we go back away your senior year at
Michigan State we had you on yeah and
this was prior to the Big Ten title game
I think with Russell Wilson now and we
were asking what you listen to in your
car and you remember what that was well
I remember singing a song for you you
know and I don't know if I ever rolled
around to it in my car but it does
happen to be Friday today yeah I know
and so and how did it go well I was a
little flat I think if I remember right
what you quittin but sometimes it's not
how you sound it's how committed you are
right you just gotta own the moment and
you own the moment there so Rebecca
Black Friday okay Paulie do we have the
audio of that of course we do okay here
we go this is a cousins friend Kirk D
cousins Friday
it's Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's lookin forward to the
weekend weekend yes No then when we
realize you were coming in I said we
have to have him in on a Friday it's
perfect how's your voice now no better
you know I mean that's a lot of years of
yelling snap counts and barking out mic
points and making audibles and it just
keeps getting raspier and raspy I can't
imagine somebody sitting next to you or
witnessing you in a car wherever you
were and you're singing that song yeah
it's been a while since I've dusted that
one on do you sing like if you're in the
car does your wife let you say I like to
sing but I like to sing in the privacy
of my own car with my tinted windows
yeah well my van yeah you you know 22
inch rims when you're rolling with the
windows down I get that yeah
was it a successful season for the
Vikings that's a great question I know I
mean the short answer is no we didn't
make the playoffs there were high
expectations
and we then deliver and so I've been
frustrated since the season and I
I usually when the season ends I look
forward to the offseason in the sense of
you know recharging the batteries rest
and getting to spend time with family
and this year and I wish the 2019 season
started tomorrow I mean I'm ready to go
and make amends for 2018 and so it's
been frustrating to know that I got to
sit here for whatever it is seven eight
months before we get back at it so it's
been a tough tough January for me
haven't been sleeping real well that
kind of a thing just because uh yeah it
just left a bad taste in my mouth away
the season finished up but the
expectation levels were so high for you
leaving Washington sure wherever
Superbowl or boss and you knew what you
were getting into oh yeah plus you get a
guaranteed contract and that's a lot of
pressure
other than that hey go out and play good
football well I mean your NFL
quarterback pressure comes with the
territory so in some sense it's like who
doesn't have pressure you know we're all
out there playing and being judged and
evaluate and it's but I don't even think
Brady had Super Bowl or bust
expectations this year on him yeah I you
know I'd agree with that the
expectations may have been hard to meet
it would have been tough to do it unless
you're the MVP of the league and win the
Super Bowl but at the same time you know
I understand the job that comes with it
and you know we just we didn't get the
job done at the end of the day and you
know again hopefully 2019 will be a
different story that story when you uh
you beat up the entire Michigan State
hockey team right that wasn't true right
that wasn't true
they said that story get out yeah you
know I still wondered it this day but
there was a a fight at the hockey house
on campus and there were some younger
football players there and for some
reason the following week on the local
news they said the word I'm getting is
the fight was instigated by by Kirk
Cousins at the time I was the backup
quarterback so nobody knew me just that
was the name he got and he and he went
with it and I wasn't there and my
teammates you know we're laughing so
hard when they heard that and so they
you know people were gonna say they're
gonna sell shirts you know on the front
i party with Kirk Cousins in the back it
was gonna say late nights and hockey
fights
and those never got sold by say it's
true
well you know looking back maybe that
would have helped my brand I don't know
don't mess with Kirk D cousin because
he's gonna he's gonna take it to you so
why don't you let us answer you like
that when you ask the question we never
get a chance to dan it wasn't a question
it was an exclamation point people have
put a question mark I know that was I
was telling the guy there in the hallway
ice I was telling him you like that and
you don't have a choice oh yeah because
so many people they want to judge your
play and decide whether you know well
I'm not gonna look at this or that but
I'm gonna say he's just I made up my
mind he can't play or he can't play and
so I looked at at him and I just felt
like you know what you may not like me
you may not want to be behind me but you
like that there we go
McLovin does an impersonation of that
cost you dressed like Kirk Cousins on
Halloween I did and the best part was I
did the gif or Jif version where I keep
walking back and forth because no one
ever doesn't want it's always but you
trademarked it we did yeah we
trademarked in I think t2 to have the
trademark you have to show proof that
you're using it so I don't know how much
you've been using it as of late we did
put it to use originally you just you
just used it here I got your draft
profile okay you interested in this I
would love to hear now all the greats
have done from Rogers to Brees they've
all read there now this is what was said
about you coming out of Michigan State I
took out the good stuff good I love it
nobody hear about that now I'll let you
read it
okay by the way when I did this with
Drew Brees Bree said can I keep this
that's good and he put it Russell Wilson
asked for his as well because he said
I'm gonna put in my locker yeah and
these are actual things that were said
about you in fact Russell Wilson wanted
names attack he wanted to know who said
sorry I think all of us that are you
know we all got a little chip on our
shoulder you know it all comes with the
territory
okay all right so here you go your
cousin this is what's said about Kirk D
cousins coming out who have come his
accuracy when throwing deep
questionable has not shown he can make
the flash place to move the offense and
win games for his team he will need
talent around him to succeed which
limits his value he is not a very strong
deep thrower lacks the ability to
manipulate defensive backs Kirk Cousins
has a problem with pocket pressure he
often does not handle it well tends to
panic and the quality of his mechanics
tends to drop causing poor throws and
then the last one is based on his
production and leadership at Michigan
State Cousins has late-round value to a
team looking for someone to compete for
a backup role what ma bothers you the
most about that well the one that you
could probably most quickly just say is
is silly is the not strong and throwing
the deep ball yeah I mean just I think
you have to watch tape and and be over
you know manipulate defensive backs who
in college is dropping back and like
going through progressions and moving
people with their eyes I mean that's
like a year five six seven in the NFL
you start to really do that to the level
that they're evaluating this so I don't
I don't know of a lot of guys you're
like oh we're gonna take him 10th
overall because he manipulates you know
pocket pressure like okay yeah there's a
guy in my face who doesn't struggle with
that so you know some of it just gets to
be guys we're chasing our tail here but
you know I had going back to the
frustration of 2018 I mean the whole
thing of you know win games I mean
that's what it's about
yeah and that's why I'm not sleeping
well because I'm sitting here going you
know 2015 was 9 and 7 we made the
playoffs but we lost the first round
2016 was 87 and 1a 2017 was 7 and 9 2018
was 87 and 1 and so four years now of
essentially hovering around 500
eventually you know that's got to change
you got to get to 12 and for 11 and 5 13
3 whatever's got to be got to get there
and you got to win playoff games that's
what it's all about so that's gonna that
knock is gonna be there until you go out
there and and win and win and win and I
understand it's a team game but that's
what I'm still chewing I don't I don't
want y'all fired up here you know I got
some fire I got something that I will
fix that um I got brisket
over there I got the trigger grill is
your trigger I am a big trigger guy yeah
and I do believe that you are sleeping
well as you have the same bed I have you
have the Sleep Number bed yep what's
your Sleep Number so I sleep at 70 I'm
75 okay we're a lot common yeah we do
good-looking skinny ankles skinny
I don't know that skinny ankle thing
with baseball too lot of scouts look at
that skinny ankle we want broad
shoulders skinny ankles I got one of
those to be a slice number beds the
officials sleep and wellness partner of
the NFL big fans of a Sleep Number as
well a title sponsor here of the Dan
Patrick show it's always great to see
you yeah don't be a stranger like once
you became a big time quarterback then
you started to blow us off here you know
I blew you off during the season I'm a
busy man I got a lot going on I got a
second kid on the way now Super Bowl
week especially Friday I got four kids I
have time for you well I ignore them
just to spend time I brought in Trager
you did bring in Trey okay
by the way would you like to smoke not
yeah I mean we'll smoke the brisket
would you like to smoke McLovin with a
couple of passes I would like that I got
some I got some great sleep last night I
got a 75 score on my sleep IQ look at
you so I'm feeling good you know my wife
sleep numbers only thirty so I'm a 70
and for years she would complain to me
that but it's two beds in one well
that's the thing yeah two separate
numbers and so she would say Kirk we got
to get a Sleep Number and I would say
you know I'm too cheap you know I'm too
cheap and finally this deal with Sleep
Number last year they got 18 hundred
players now with Sleep Number beds and
so I've I've got my bed and Julie's at
30 and I'm a 70 and she sleeps tonight
away I sleep well she said C we should
have gotten this all on I said you're
right so I got to stop being cheap that
bed may have kept your marriage together
I think so that's best things that's how
great that now another kid on the way so
awesome well I
I'm just saying okay I'm just saying
your results may vary in bed I'm just
saying it is what it has to do for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app